[Music]
foreign
it was a triumphant welcome for a leader
who must feel triumphant the band
heralding not just president XI but a
new era too under his continued control
party Congress like this happens every
five years
a ceremonial show of unity a show of
diversity too and with the mission to
select China's new leaders
according to precedent she should now
step down 10 years in power the limit
but it's almost certain he won't his
speech and enshrining of sorts of shi's
path she's Vision she's China
over nearly two hours he detailed
China's winds and its challenges the
party's faithful followed Faithfully
but there were hints too about policy
tough talk on Taiwan but no sense an
invasion's forthcoming
we will continue to make utmost efforts
for peaceful reunification but never
promised to renounce the use of force
and we reserve the option to taking all
measures necessary
complete reunification must be realized
and it can be without a doubt be
realized
the Applause for that was long and loud
but many were hoping for more on covid a
hint of an end to Draconian lockdowns
they will have been left disappointed
in responding to the sudden outbreak of
covid-19 we put the people and their
lives above all else and tenaciously
pursued a dynamic zero covered policy
but it was not a point the president
dwelt on and scenes like this may be why
rare and brave protests this week one
Banner called Shia dictator beneath the
control there's frustration and the
party must know it in the streets of
Beijing paranoia was palpable roads
closed guards increased more people than
usual locked down she's Vision was to
make China richer and stronger he has
but not via liberal reform the vision
that's in it highly
nationalistic China that takes pride and
is completely Unapologetic about its
place in the world not looking to say we
need to learn from the outside world
saying no the learning days are over we
now have things to teach the world
that's a very Xi Jinping view of the
world also no compromise I would say
with any other sort of liberal issues
presidency is more powerful more revered
than any Chinese leader in decades but
he's pulled control purged his Rivals
and stepped up surveillance and
censorship his path to a strong China
has had costs to his people and it's a
path China will continue to tread Helena
Smith Sky News in Shanghai